we're joined on the line my Dave Rubin
David is host of the Reuben report and
author of the new book don't burn this
book it is available everywhere now Dave
good to talk to you sir
Shapiro you're sick of me yet we've been
talking a lot lately all right we're in
lockdown together apparently yeah I mean
well the only thing that separates us is
the is the vagary of zoom so his new
book is don't burn this book and it
really is about how Dave travelled from
being a guy who was on The Young Turks
to being a conservative you know works
over at blaze TV and it's also about the
censorship culture that America is
currently engaged in it's incredible to
watch as that censorship culture sort of
shifts and and moves into pandemic phase
because there is this sort of censorship
culture that has emerged when it comes
to the pandemic what do you make of the
bizarre spectacle of so many people who
don't want to have open conversations
about serious public policy issues when
it comes to this pandemic Dave yeah well
first off then you know if I would have
had anyone intro me on any show three
years ago and say that I could be
considered anything close to a
conservative you know I probably would
have gone bananas and now you know as I
tell you all the time defending my
liberal principles has become a
conservative position so I would say yes
in many ways I now AM conservative it
just is as far as the text censorship
and everything else I mean look we all
know that we've had a major problem with
big tech and that YouTube and Google and
Twitter and Facebook have bloomed to
large over too much of our lives for
long we all got in for free except we
didn't realize that it was our souls
that were going to pay the price and now
they own everything about us and you
know just in the last couple days
majeski the CEO of YouTube you and I
have had some private contact with you
know she's basically said if you go if
you put anything on YouTube against
w-h-o rules or edicts or whatever you
want to call it that they're gonna take
that stuff down and it's so incredibly
dangerous at so many levels first up the
w-h-o is not an infallible organization
there is no such thing as an infallible
organization now they're supposed to be
a scientific organization that's
supposed to figure out how to deal with
with these types of pandemics but you
know science is constantly trying to
find better answers for everything so
that they themselves have been wrong on
things I mean let's not forget that just
what
five six weeks ago they were telling
people not to wear masks now there's
something everyone to wear masks so the
idea that they're going to run around
taking videos off YouTube gets to the
broader point which is that right now
our ability to communicate with each
other
and especially in a time of growing a
virus where it's like you know you and I
can't meet for coffee as we've done you
know you mean it's like we don't live
that far apart we can't even do that
right now our Fourth Amendment the right
to assemble is in effect been suspended
now we can debate whether the measures
you know are too much or too little or
the rest of it but we had a big tech
problem before and we have a way bigger
big tech problem right now because there
is literally no other way to communicate
and we better start thinking about it
and fast and in many ways it's too late
because too many of us acquiesced for
too long so let's talk about the you
walk down here in California both you
and I are in lockdown in California the
state government continues to want to
lock down apparently until the aliens
come or something something is gonna
change months from now and then we will
all not be locked down anymore it's
interesting to see how this has become
such a political issue the lock downs
and I think a lot of it has to do with
the fact that there is this widespread
perception on the right that I think is
at least half justified that there are
folks on the Left who want to take
advantage of the situation in order to
radically reshift the nature of the of
the relationship between government and
the citizenry it seems like all the
people who are out there saying data and
science are driving this are ignoring
the fact that data in science we can all
agree on that the question is competing
values including values of freedom
Liberty quality of life and economic
health yeah well you're hitting all the
right points there I mean this actually
is very much in line with what my book
is about and as you know you've written
a couple books I finished writing this
thing back in July and the fact that
it's so relevant now shows you that
time-tested ideas are the way to go and
not just oh we have a crisis and let's
figure out how all of the things that we
want to be true all of the ways we want
to rejigger the economy we can suddenly
take advantage of a crisis and make
happen which is exactly what aoc and the
rest of the Cruz look for people like
you and I you know la where we live has
had a little resurgence of I would say a
conservative and libertarian think think
spot
basically I mean look you're here I'm
here players here Peter teal left San
Francisco to come to Los Angeles so that
tells you something good was brewing
here but you know been the subsystems
that you know for people that believe
broadly the things that you and I
believe in and probably most of your
listeners believe in it's like we live
in Los Angeles with the progressive
mayor we live in California with a
progressive governor and you know at the
same time it's not like the state is
working if progressive policies work is
big government high tax policies work
well then our teachers wouldn't be on
strike all the time but they're always
on strike and then do they blame they
somehow blame the Republicans who
haven't been in power here in decades so
yes we're seeing a certain set of
political people you need this
opportunity to basically be like oh the
stuff that I've wanted to try forever
that really hasn't been in place well
this is just the perfect time to do it
and you know for me personally you know
where I fall sort of on the libertarian
side of things and I'm just going to be
one of the people that's just going to
keep pushing to start freeing us and I
think there's going to be a cost with
that and we have to honestly talk about
that cause you know it we could open up
tomorrow and we know that restaurants
will maybe have less people there and
maybe you'll still have to wears the
mask but we have to start opening you
know we're going to forget the old world
that's what I'm worried about we're six
or seven weeks into this thing and it
almost feels like a lifetime ago that we
could just walk around and be free and
you could go for a beer and grab a slice
of pizza and I don't want to go too much
longer with this because we will forget
and then you know what's on the other
side of that well it probably looks a
lot like China and frankly I don't want
to live in China so Dave obviously you
know your movement from sort of the the
political left to the political right is
particularly interesting for folks who
don't know that Dave is a gay man who is
married that means that you know that
that makes him an absolute outcast among
people on the left if you are gay and
you are a conservative or libertarian
then you have sinned against the against
the the left on a deep level I mean I
sort of get this because Jews are also
not supposed to be particularly
conservative which is particularly weird
because Jewish values obviously on a
traditional level don't align with the
Democratic Party but but Dave how it
what does
or comparison story between you know
being a gay man in the in the sort of
conservative libertarian world versus
being conservative in the in the leftist
world yeah look it's sort of interesting
because first off you know I like the
way you preface that because you know
the simple fact that I'm gay or married
or whatever really has very little to do
with my political beliefs or my beliefs
about the world in general other than I
can't say that it has no no attachment
to it right so it is something it does
make you look at the world from a little
bit of an outsider perspective what I
can tell you is this when I was when I
was part of the left there was sort of
an obsession with my sexuality because
they can sort of use that ah see we are
good we have gay people we have black
people we have women and of course you
know at the surface level that sort of
sounds right it's like oh well here are
all these people cheering me on they're
cheering me on because I'm gay how
wonderful and as I've left the left and
embraced by people on the right what I
found is because people on the right
believe in individual rights and people
are there on the right basically our
lives on let live it's like nobody
really cares nobody I I don't know
anyone that cares and and the contingent
that really cared you know let's say
like the Rick Santorum Mike Huckabee
contingent well first off I would
absolutely always defend their religious
liberty just as I always defend your
religious liberty but secondly you're
not really screaming about gay marriage
anymore the ship the ship has sailed so
I view this more as a non-issue on the
right you know particularly Rotarians
who just want the government added it
all together but I would say you know
one of the things that I think is the
best sort of political bright spot we
have right now is conservatives I think
in a new way are living up to their
ideals conservatives really are I think
trying to allow other people to live a
little bit differently and it doesn't
mean that they endorse it or personally
love it or gonna do it themselves but I
think conservatives understand that you
know unless you want to live in a
religious theocracy then there's going
to be some different people here and and
I'm very anything about that and then
most of the other things about being on
the right related to small government in
states rights and and taxes and foreign
policy those things are just an
extension
once you start thinking about things
they just start making a lot more sense
so I would say my evolution is one that
that's pretty obvious and it's sort of
why I get to hate that I get because you
know the left doesn't like letting you
walk and they really don't want to let a
minority walk they can't have they can't
have gays just go in and say and what
they think they can't let a black person
get out there like Larry elder and say
what he thinks they can't have a woman
like Nikki hailey or Sarah Huckabee
Sanders or anyone else just get out
there and say what they think they want
to control you and I just refuse to live
like that Dave Rubin his new book is
don't burn this book you can also listen
to the Ruben Barker will watch it over
at blaze TV Dave really appreciate the
time good luck with the book it's
already soaring up the bestseller charts
Congrats on it
Shapiro thanks a lot and stay safe my
friends
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content